und damit kommen wir auch schon zum
paukenschlag urteil von gestern ein
verwaltungsgericht verlangt verhängt
kann man sagen fahrverbote in essen und
auf teilen der a40
die a40 da kannst du das ruhrgebiet auch
komplett abschaffen oder an die
holländer verkaufen keine ahnung
es ist eine katastrophe immerhin gab es
jetzt eine art fortschritt gerade mal
zwei autobauer vw und mercedes zahlen
wohl doch eventuell für hardware
nachrüstungen aber nur in einer handvoll
städte und laut herrn scheuer erst nach
2020 in wenigen monaten kommen
fahrverbote
was sagt man denn zu so einem scheiß
kompromiss dann kommen wir sagen aus
stroh gefüllt in wessen auftrag scheuer
war eine rhetorische frage was ich immer
sage gut dass wir den an die haben das
sage ich mir so oft meine damen und
herren
seine auftraggeber wollen jetzt
unbedingt dass wir uns alle neue euro 6
diesel kaufen
eur 6 und die lösung seien dabei sind
hier auch dreckig von 74 unter realen
bedingungen getestet modellen haben
gerade mal sieben die grenzwerte
eingehalten
zehn davon überschreiten das erlaubte
ums zehnfache aber die dürfen weiter in
die städte fahren wirklich manchmal wird
der steuersachen dargelegt mir die
zündkerze durch das eine nämlich den
fehler manipulationen haben mit der
jetzigen situation der fahrverbote und
der probleme in den innenstädten nichts
zu tun denn die schadstoffe so lernten
sie eigentlich angegeben waren dann
werden auch die emissionen noch
insgesamt nicht so hoch
frau slomka jetzt glaube ich komme in
echt schiefe argumentation
ich habe das interview ja live gesehen
und ich konnte es nicht glauben
die fahrverbote haben mit manipulationen
nichts zu tun
mal ehrlich was hat der scheuer vor dem
interview geraucht für diesel besitzer
ist scheu inzwischen echt der antichrist
das muss man ja heuer unterscheidet
weiter katz recht zwischen beschiss also
summe software und legalem beschiss
durch völlig unrealistische abgastest
mehrere firmen haben nachweislich
funktionierende hardware nachrüstsätze
entwickelt und warten jetzt sehnsüchtig
auf die zulassung hier neulich bei
illner erklärt der vw-chef dies einem
kunden warum hardware nachrüstung
trotzdem und verbrechen am auto sind
ich bin mir auch nicht sicher ob der
schmidts das will sie liefern das auto
dort ab und heizspirale reihen der
tablet rausgerissen sie kriegen
zusatzinstrument und nach vorne durch
geburt zu lochen im teppich die bilder
eingeklebt schläuche von vorne nach
hinten die ganze prozedur dauert zehn
stunden reserverad sie abgeben kriegen
sie nicht mehr zurück
[Applaus]
albtraum und sie lachen demnächst
fahrverbote in köln frankfurt stuttgart
berlin dem ruhrgebiet hamburg jetzt
schon denn diese fahrer wird
flächendeckend ausgesperrt ausgesperrt
und keiner macht was man lässt die leute
alleine
letzte woche gab es für betroffene
immerhin post vom kraftfahrtbundesamt
weil sie das mitgekriegt haben mit
tollen ratschlägen wie zitat im rahmen
der umtauschaktion es ist kein umtausch
ist ein autokauf können betroffene
bürger einen maßgeblichen beitrag zur
verbesserung der luftqualität in unseren
städten leisten ist das zu fassen
jetzt schickt man die verantwortung für
saubere luft komplett auf den betrogenen
dieselfahrer geht's noch deutschland
drohen fahrverbote und wer ist schuld
die autobauer
von wegen die tun was sie können der
verkehrsminister hat einfach nur befehle
befolgt und damit ist ja wohl klar wer
schuld ist der dumme deutsche
dieselfahrer ja klar du du hast jedoch
ein auto gekauft dass die grenzwerte
überschreitet wie asozial und scheiße
kann man die reihen im prospekt standort
dass er sauber ist schnauze du wirst
mich an du dummes schwein los lasst die
karre stehen und kauft ihr neues auto
vom wieder da muss ich erstmal meine
frau fragen sofort schneller
ja ja so gut läuft du umfeld sei
sie sahen einen lehrfilm des
kraftfahrt-bundesamts und der deutschen
logistik und fassbar
da fragt man sich schon was ist das denn
bitte für eine behörde dieses kraftfahrt
bundesamt die haben doch die ganzen
dreckschleudern jahrelang zugelassen
obwohl sie wussten sie unrealistisch die
abgastests sind jetzt verschicken die
briefe wo drinsteht kauft euch
gefälligst eine neue cover hier auf dem
brief stehen oben rechts sogar ist kein
witz die verkaufs hotlines von vw
daimler und bmw ist eine werbebroschüre
wir schalten live ins
kraftfahrt-bundesamt dort leitet
sebastian pufpaff die presseabteilung
herbst wäre es nicht besser gewesen
wenigstens auch eine neutrale beratungs
hotline einzurichten
bitte nein quatsch dann rufen wir alle
hier am see mit einem betrogenen kunden
telefoniert die sind die auch wahnsinnig
schlecht gelaunt die lava die rechte
klinkern zordo zwar verbote hinter
verliere ich meinen job ich musste
meinen ihre verkaufen
sie sollen einfach bei bmw anrufen und
sich ein neues auto bestellen ja wir
beim kba wir stehen zur deutschen
autoindustrie
deswegen haben wir endlich
zusammengeführt was doch eh
zusammengehört unsere behörde residiert
ab sofort in einem autohaus ab klasse
oder das spart ja auch wege und ist gut
für die umwelt
sie können doch nicht werbung machen für
betrüger ja für betrüger jetzt nicht
aber zum beispiel für den neuen vw
tiguan mit zweiliter tdi und 7 gang dsg
und for motion active controller
wissen sie einen großzügigen kofferraum
klatsch mit wie sie oben funktion der
tiguan klare linien markante form und
ein dynamisches design von kraftvoller
überlegenheit tiguan das weltauto danke
blessing
aber was ist mit den menschen die sich
keinen neuen tiguan leisten können für
die teure brice letzte woche doch wie
blanker hohn
ich muss ehrlich sagen dass er den neuen
schaffen für uns gerade gar nicht in
frage kommt wissen sie wir haben vor
zwei jahren
dieses haus gekauft und renoviert wir
haben hier viele schulden ist eine junge
familie mit zwei kindern ein und drei
jahre alt und an dieser stelle ist
momentan einfach auch nicht das geld da
nicht dann liegt halt hin man ja und
bevor man sich zwei kinder an die backe
pumps hätte der ja auch einfach mal
überlegen können was ihnen wirklich
wichtig ist knattern oder auto fahren
sie mal zu ja ich bin für verkehr aber
wenn ich was rein steckt ist das immer
noch ein autoschlüssel
[Gelächter]
aber sie sind doch eine bundesbehörde
sie müssen sich zuerst mal entschuldigen
dass wir den ganzen beschiss über jahre
gedeckt haben jetzt passen gut auf
freundchen jeder deutsche beamte trägt
eine verantwortung für 800.000
arbeitsplätze in der autoindustrie davon
allein 100.000 anwälte die uns gegen
wütende kunden verteidigen und wir vom
kba die sind aber sogar noch proaktiv
hier
ich habe eine liste mit kunden die sich
stumpf weigern endlich einen neuen
diesel zu kaufen was man auch da besuche
ich jetzt jeden einzelnen persönlich und
nehmen am alten fahrzeug eine hardware
nachrüstung vor
ja so als motivation und wenn das auch
nicht reicht dann klinge ich bei den
leuten zu hause und dann breche ich den
halt die beine
hier sicher und ach ja da fällt mir ein
herr welke was ist eigentlich mit ihren
euro für was ich komme da gerne man
nachher vorbei zum persönlichen
beratungsgespräch ist
ich kaufe mir 9 sebastian aus buchbach
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]